Australia is pledging nearly 35 million
dollars to an emergency wildlife
recovery program as the country deals
with its worst bushfire season on record
it's estimated more than a billion
animals have been lost already this
includes a large number of koalas which
were listed as vulnerable to extinction
even before the fires Jamie yuccas shows
us how specially trained dogs are being
used to help save these iconic animals
koalas are only found in Australia and
because of the brush fires they've been
hit particularly hard
it's estimated that here in New South
Wales a third of the population has died
in other areas the numbers are higher
that's why these dogs are so important
they sniff out and find the most
vulnerable yes Tommy Emma and Becky are
working to save as many koalas as their
noses will find which koala Ernie
funding
steve austin is their trainer he's been
working with dogs for 30 years and says
they're constantly learning and adapting
the beauty of the dog is that it's not
got no bias it won't go oh well they
can't be a corner over there there has
to be a koala so but the dog just uses
his nose and that's what it's so that's
so good this canine team is specifically
trained to find injured koalas sometimes
by tracking the scent of their waste
known as scat yes good boy and for that
he gets the ultimate reward for him
which is the 98 cents 1000 so when he
sat down does that indicate to you
that's where the Koala is exactly months
of fires in Australia have had a
devastating impact on the koala
population which was already on the
verge of extinction the World Wildlife
Fund believes there were between one and
200,000 koalas across Australia before
the fire season the group estimates more
than 30,000 have died although the final
toll won't be known for months why are
koalas so special to Australia they've
got that lovely ambience about them they
don't hurt nothing they just sit and eat
and they're very Australian because they
found our else in the world so you we
have
but it's very important that we do koala
so far the season Austin's canine team
has located 16 koalas experts are then
called in to rescue the animals around
45 koalas are being treated for burns at
the Port Macquarie koala hospital north
of Sydney president sue Ashton says
she's grateful for the dog teams but
actually streamline the whole process
one is a quite just great they hide
themselves very well and particularly if
they've been traumatized ecologist say
because koalas breed so slowly it could
take a hundred years for the population
to rebuild
that's why saving just one is so
important they gentle die small
creatures they don't hurt anybody they
don't generally they don't have each
other and they just deserve to live are
you concerned about how well the species
will bounce back very concerned but it r
is a light and the light is now that
people have seen the plight of koala
maybe we can get up our backsides and
with the help of the government and
like-minded people we can actually do
something that will help them these are
just three of eight dogs trained to do
this work throughout the entire country
that's why as it becomes safer to do so
Steve wants to get these dogs into as
many areas as possible for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Arcadia Australia well so
hard to see those wounded bears
whimpering it's just they seem like
little babies the way they're crying out
you can see the pain enter into the mind
of a koala for a moment I imagine you
just got hit with a fire now there's a
dog dog coming next to me are you here
to help are there to help
you